let's quickly pick up on our caller from
the 708 because 708 has been just
holding on for so long
708 what's your name and where are you
calling from hey David I'm John from
Chicago hey John what's up um not too
much John by the way yes John I misspoke
and I did here you know it's no problem
it's probably the New Yorker and they
even though I'm in Chicago um I have a
question about your your opinions on the
response that people have been given
relative to everything lately in America
now I know there have been good stories
and it seems that there have been people
that have been almost you know taking
care of their fellow man and brother and
sister excuse me but at the same point
in time it seems like there are a lot of
people that have been vitriolic and very
dark and I was wondering if do you think
this is more or less a morality or an
education thing or possibly both because
I've been a fan of yours for a while and
I highly respect your intellectual take
on certain sociological things you know
I wish I had a strong answer for you
here's here's the thing I have thought
for a long time and I think it's
probably a naive thought that if there's
really a global calamity or a global an
incident of global importance I
sometimes will say imagine if we found
intelligent alien life that this would
so quickly make all of our day-to-day
conflicts obviously irrelevant and not
worth fighting over and we would unite
against or with or whatever like you
know we would realize we're not alone in
the universe this is a major step
forward for mankind we would fix or
instantly resolve a lot of the minor
conflicts or we've got a global pandemic
this risks killing millions and millions
of people if we don't actually deal with
it everybody's coming together and
you've got you know people with
ridiculous signs wearing no masks all
the best
gather in all these different states
people calling for the firing of dr.
Anthony foul like it would almost be
insane if aliens did show up and we sat
them down and we said listen we've got
this global pandemic we've got no real
treatment the vaccines a year off and
here's what these protesters are doing
and here's what people are demanding
about dr. fuchi the aliens would say
what the hell is wrong with Homo sapiens
they would get back on that spaceship
and fly away right because it's insane
behavior so I don't know if it's
political polarization that's causing
this I don't know if it's ignorant
that's causing this I don't know if it's
bad people or a combination of all of it
but it's if we can't come together
around this I don't know that we can
ever really come together as a human
race yeah I would totally agree and I'm
happy to hear you bring that analogy
about aliens and I know you have other
callers but I just as a teacher because
I'm a private music teacher and because
of the obvious virus my life has changed
quite a bit
relative to doing everything remotely
and teaching guitar bass and violin
remotely is kind of annoying but the
thing that I've noticed the most is that
some of the students that I have around
here that I could still kind of safely
go to their house and teach them because
I'm obviously fine myself there's always
this philosophical argument that tends
to be posed to me because I think people
don't realize that a lot of people are
affected like I just lost my uncle last
week ago in New York to the virus and
stuff like that and I mentioned it's one
of my students parents and they were
basically going off on how it's not just
Trump's fault and stuff like that in
which I could arguably do the mental
gymnastics honestly to see that argument
but there's also a point in time where
I'm like shouldn't you just kind of be a
little bit more compassionate relative
to wanting to be right like I think
Stephen Fry said this in a in a in a
lecture that he
but he's like the biggest problem with
humanity right now
is not the point of being like our
biggest problem is that we want to be
right and not be effective yes
towards everyone else I don't disagree
with that it is true that this is not
just Trump's fault every country is
dealing with it and the idea that we
would have had no deaths is a silly idea
Trump's response has been a failure but
it is bigger than Trump that doesn't you
know excuse Donald Trump's behavior John
I really appreciate it I've got to run
to a commercial break but it's been so
great hearing from you I'm sorry I was
not able to get two more calls today but
we will take calls again and I
appreciate everybody who did call in